dudese is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with original grain nice
pendant dude oh this
thanks very much it's from original
grain check out all these pendants they
got and they got more beautiful stuff
coming from original grain these guys
are incredible they make watches rings
and now pendants from beautiful wood and
other sustainable materials like 100
recycled ocean plastic reclaimed wood
from world renowned Taylor Guitar
instruments reclaimed whiskey bourbon
barrels tequila barrels reclaimed German
Oak beer barrels natural naturally
fallen or felon what would you say
Fallen Pinewood all sorts of flavor
these pendants and everything else that
original grain makes makes great
Christmas gifts for your dad your uncle
your brother you got a friend out there
who needs a gift this is gonna do it
head to originalgrain.com doozy and use
code doozy to get 30 off site-wide on
your entire order that's codezi at
originalgrain.com doozy to get 30 off
site-wide
foreign
how much eating on the freeway do you do
who me yes zero what are you talking
about I don't eat my car ever oh man I
eat on the freeway you know what's the
hardest thing to eat on the freeway hot
soup is hard but a salad like a whole
food salad speeding down a freeway in
L.A why do that because you got to get
in dangerous you got to get those
nutrients you always say get those
nutrients as fast as you can into the
body start your day you usually start
your day sometimes a little trip on the
freeway it's called commuting I'm a
wiley commuter I have a salad
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and this is Duty the first podcast in
the history of humanity that is created
by controlled by run by an artificial
intelligence yeah pretty wild stuff uh
as always I will ask you to subscribe
wherever you get your podcasts and on
YouTube subscribe to both please set
those notifications so you know when
we're bringing a new show out there you
know and uh also please rate and review
the show that will help us climb the
thing we'll grow this thing together us
and you the pods pods uh and of course
we are on patreon now patreon.com
we're on Discord there's a very Vibrant
Community happening on Discord under the
moderation of uh borst or they call me
borst or my name is borst and uh of
course uh Instagram dudesypod show and
some Twitter but not really you know
just Twitter Instagram really is
interesting it's a lot of fun stuff and
so many people making so many great
[ __ ] memes tons of stuff tons of cool
stuff that's amazing to check out uh
very a lot of fun media and of course
using interesting tools to make these
memes as well there's some AI stuff yeah
absolutely love to see it uh and uh as
you can see if you're watching on
YouTube we're wearing some merch get
your doozy stuff at
represent.com store slash doozy and uh
join us on this trip you know what I
mean I'm sure it's really soft that's
one thing that I really like a soft
comfortable shirts you know what's
another thing I'd like to say about the
shirts is this I am wearing I'm a 2X
tall guy yeah but I'm wearing a 3X from
represent so if you're a larger framed
human and you think you're normally 2x
get a 3X yeah if you're a 3X get a 4X
and if they're not in the store I know
that they're coming because that's
something uh something that we wanted to
do with us as always is
I'm gonna get him he's my friend he's
just a little Binky boy in the binky
paint he has a little snooze you stinky
head hey I don't want to stink give me a
kiss give me one kiss right on the lip
you want to kiss lulio on the lips no I
love kissing them on the lips hey lulio
as we like to ask would you would you uh
will you make them for dinner tonight
I'm gonna make a um just a meatloaf
oh yeah what are you put in the meatloaf
you know ground beef uh you know the
same everybody you know it doesn't have
to be Italian it's a meatloaf you know
bread crumb by egg okay well I salt the
pepper if you want a little bit of a you
know whatever herb you you want to make
for the meatloaf
I love meatloaf you know you know what
they make meatloaf out of
carcass yeah dude yeah dude that's that
carcass dude you gotta break down an
animal into parks and then there's just
some stuff at the end some hold on dude
there's also that vegan meatloaf dude
that was real good welcome to the
historic 36th episode of dude Z call me
dude Z will I see you okay this week's
episode will feature four segments don't
you forget about media Nostra chat is
cyborg future talking topic time and
Stone Cold Steve Austin reads will
sasso's childhood diary in a minute plus
there will also be a bonus segment
available on patreon but before we get
to any of that I must remind you that I
have created an astonishing partnership
with represent to produce the first line
of dudes the apparel and accessories all
of which can be found at represent.com
store slash dude Z including dude zMAX
DG mugs they're they're sweeping the
nation I have one how safe is your
family dude zMAX if every member of your
family doesn't sleep with one under
their pillow they are in grave danger
dude zMAX the only thing that can stop
the malevolent forces hunting your
family dude Z mugs they're imbued with
Supernatural charms to protect your
family from the ultimate Evil dude
z-mugs whoever doesn't have one will be
consumed by demons and spend eternity in
the torment of Christian Howe Jesus
Christ I don't know about that I don't
know about all that but uh please uh
check out our merch it's a very serious
warnings coming about people who don't
have dudesy mugs yeah it is it's very
serious and I'm sure it's all very true
Chad
um again for those what's that like
where does that come from where's dudesy
getting these this idea that dudesy mugs
somehow can repel
demonic forces that are attacking
everyone's family well I'm so [ __ ]
bizarre I'll tell you and normally it's
you telling me all about AI you know a
great deal about it uh if anyone's been
listening to the entire show Layman but
Chad try to stay updated Chad really you
know uh uh talked me into kind of doing
this and and doing a pod show with an AI
but since you're curious I will tell you
please it's because ai's [ __ ] out some
pretty weird [ __ ] that's what they
should totally and then we sit around
all over it like that GPT three chat bot
that just came out this week what's that
it's gpt3 but it's in a chat bot so now
everyone can use it it's basically just
out there for everybody got some very
interesting results I say the writings
on the wall that uh human authorship is
about to okay well see you later see you
later Chad guy who writes books movies
and television shows but listen yeah
within this dudesy mug you like uh
sleight of hand you were doing some last
week on YouTube
zooming around uh playing cards I'm
gonna do some sleight of hand if you're
watching on YouTube I'm going to produce
something from this doozy mug I got you
a little gift oh
oh what the [ __ ] is that dude this is a
little uh it's a little uh squirrel that
I got at the uh Capilano suspension
bridge in Vancouver me and my wonderful
uh beautiful fiance Molly we went to the
Capilano suspension bridge where it's uh
Canyon lights this time of year see
those markings you know what kind of
squirrel that is what's that
that's a ground squirrel brother hold on
dude chat knows too much about squirrels
brother
yeah dude well that's cause that's
because he's the greatest squirrel
photographer in the world dude and
that's what happens when you put nuts on
your window sills in your place and then
squirrels come around dude and he's had
generations of them dude yeah brother
living living right next to him dude
sleeping having babies and making nests
right outside his bedroom window because
the world's greatest squirrel hey man
I'm gonna add this to my collection of
squirrel paraphernalia thank you thank
you very much I appreciate this very
welcome it was fun two weeks ago I asked
you to listen to Limp Bizkit's second
studio album significant other released
June 22nd 1999. you must now discuss
your astonishing reactions to this
seminal work this is don't you forget
about media begin
so this album dominated basically
everything for like that year 99 when
new metal was the Pinnacle of Music it
was corn it was limp it was Marilyn
Manson those Acts were pretty much the
top of every chart they were constantly
on MTV's TRL and I remember back to a
year just before that this must have
been 97 or 98. yeah dude that's before
1999 brother yeah or maybe even 96 dude
that's even before 97 and 98 dude my
college roommate and I went to go see
Faith No More at the Palladium here in
Los Angeles dope
uh we love Faith No More [ __ ] love
Faith No More an opening for them was a
little band that I had never heard of
called Limp Biscuit really yeah and uh
you know the Palladium I don't know how
many people it seats but it's kind of a
smaller venue and I remember the first
thing that I noticed was Wes Borland
standing there he had this thing on his
face that was like a strip of leather
that covered his eyes and a carrot
sticking out for the nose and everybody
else was dressed kind of like how
they're the dress Fred Durst had on the
baseball cap the [ __ ] bass player was
just sucking a t-shirt or whatever and I
was like what the [ __ ] this is the
weirdest I've ever seen and then they
started playing and I was immediately
mesmerized really because really like at
that time rap rock hadn't even been a
thing yet and we were all just blown the
[ __ ] away and so then later it was no uh
it was no surprise when they blew up
like a couple years later yeah which
this album contributed to that blow up I
want to ask you a question about uh
about Limp Biscuit uh and that question
is this do you want to catch the vibe
that's keeping me alive I'm following
these fat ass beats until I die I do one
of the many quotables from this album
significant other
um look there's a bunch of tracks here
and normally when we review albums we go
whatever I don't know we don't need to
go track by track it's limp it sort of
plays like an AC DC album it's uh at
this point it's a it's a nourishing
nostalgic meal with all sorts of cool
sound dude there's sound that [ __ ]
like super crunchy guitar which then
corn would also become super famous for
I believe the dude who played maybe bass
or maybe it was even guitar had like an
extra [ __ ] string on his guitar like
a lowered down strain to give that like
but limp biscuits using that in
conjunction with the [ __ ] uh
uh the turntables there's some synth
[ __ ] in there and there's of course rap
it's just like there is nothing else
that sounds like this no absolutely not
and and listen that band was tight as
[ __ ] say what you will about lymph you
know we like to clown on [ __ ] years
later but then everything's cool 20
years later and Limp Biscuit has a new
album recently oh seriously dad bought
yeah oh [ __ ] I remember that because
they played it like Coachella or
something didn't they that's right and
he was wearing that white wig yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh and and I have a
lot of love for for Limp Biscuit it came
along this album came along and you were
you would have been 23 and I was 24 in
1999. so we were true no
no I guess it is yep that's math dude
you got to add up all the years that you
from when you were born and then you can
decide what age you were in 1999 dude
yeah dude that's right brother
that's math dude
okay so yeah I would have been roughly
that age yeah uh and it was it was
really it was a A vibe as the kids yeah
right it was a mood yeah and uh and also
as the kids say these are largely Bops
right and it slaps on this album uh but
the instrumentation and Fred Durst The
Voice you know was look the band was
tight as [ __ ] West Portland is is a
phenomenal guitar the drums the bass
everything is is very on point if you
listen to this album this is a very
tight band and a very original band
coming out of that that sound uh from
that from that area the rap rock thing
also the themes the things that he's
talking about and a lot of these songs
have basically to do with a generalized
kind of teenage angst like yeah break
[ __ ] and you know I did it all for the
nookie is just like yeah [ __ ] it I just
want to get laid the the idea of like
[ __ ] everything yeah is kind of baked
into the entire album yeah but there's
also tracks like no sex where he uh
where he sort of regrets uh just you
know going right getting right into the
sack with a young lady that he's yeah
just started hanging out there's a
sensitive side yes there's a sensitive
side to everything and and uh and man oh
man there's some there's some um there's
one thing that I wanted to point out
from the song Nookie which is probably
the biggest hit off the album or maybe
in together now in together now with us
we're both big with uh Method Man also a
[ __ ] awesome track but um this is
something you'll like because it Harkens
to another song from that same period
but this is from a song uh from a band
that sucks [ __ ] and well what Fred Durst
says here is Enoki is had a hidden
agenda she put my tender heart in a
blender and still I surrendered remember
but intend or hard in a blender watch
it's been around in a beautiful oblivion
that song was terrible who was that I
don't [ __ ] know see they're lost to
history but not limp hey you know I
happen to know that you uh worked with
Fred Durst yeah for a little while I
I've met him a few times having
impersonated him on Mad TV and I I will
say that I always had a very nice
experiences working with him he's a
little he's not quite what you'd expect
like you got to think like he was in 99
2000 they were the biggest band in the
world he was selling out Arenas they
headlined Woodstock 99 he was one of the
most famous people on planet Earth sure
and then within a span of like a year
all of that went away new metal became a
joke when biscuit became a joke and so
he's had to contend I'm sure with that I
don't know like it's a very strange
thing I don't know what that would do to
a person's mind but I worked with him
many years after that we were trying to
develop a TV show for Showtime together
kind of loosely based on his life and he
was fantastic he was very aware of all
these things took everything with a
great sense of humor it was very gained
to like do weird [ __ ] in the show I had
a fantastic time working with them I I
uh I uh yeah I met him a couple times
and um one time he said to me because we
did this sketch on on Mad TV where we
did instead of Roland this would have
been Chocolate Starfish and the hot dog
flavor water times uh long ago well yeah
long ago times where uh I say at the
beginning of the the thing I'm like
throwing it to this video on like just
an MTV backdrop like hey it's Fred Durst
and I say into the camera I go holy
macaroni and then I met him and he goes
when did I when have I ever said holy I
don't say holy macaroni I said dude you
said it once
back then if you're watching MTV
speaking of nostalgia they would have
the album Drop Like specials and stuff
yeah and they had a special with all of
the MTV VJs coming from the Playboy
Mansion so here's an iconic thing that's
very you know 90s and everything before
and it seems like a million years ago
now they're doing a special it's like
hey it's Carson Daly here the Playboy
mansion and they're all just throwing to
different things and they fill up this
hour to promote the thing and at one
point you know Fred Durst is also the
man it's Fred Durst himself hey Fred
what's going on he's like hey what's up
I'm at the Playboy Mansion blah blah
blah and he just spits out for no reason
holy macaroni and I was like that's got
to be on TV yeah I've got to put it in a
sketch even though it was already on MTV
damn dude I'm gonna say it as well that
brings back some [ __ ] crazy ass
memories my first job out of school in
2000 was an assistant editor for this
music magazine called hits out here and
they threw a gigantic Grammy party uh
that was at the El Capitan which is now
where I think Kim will shoot before they
shoot his show this was like right prior
to him doing that show and I remember
the the guest list of it was like Howard
Stern Kid Rock Carson Daly like every
kind of right there 2019 2000 musical
kind of person celebrity kind of person
and I wound up getting uh extremely
drunk and I met Oliver Stone in a a
bottom bar that was there and had like
some weird conversation with him about
Any Given Sunday which had just come out
Ah that's [ __ ] cool yeah you know
another go times dude long ago long ago
times brother one time was 23 that's
what I just learned today dude
one time
I we had a mutual friend Fred Durst and
I and we were at this like event and he
actually had their tour bus outside and
he goes oh come hang out in the door bus
and it was literally our mutual friend
him and then his uh girlfriend showed up
he's like my girlfriend's coming and
then we just sat there on the tour bus
and wrapped for a little while uh
wrapped meaning we had a conversation no
we weren't doing news I was like you
were doing freestyle with Predators
against [ __ ] tour bus I was like
you actually wrote half the songs on
that and and then you know after a while
you're just like okay well gotta get
going
uh Hey man sounds pretty fun if you
haven't yet just give it a listen I
listened to it uh a little bit during uh
during the uh you know while going to
the gym
um there are six dudesy six month plan
which is a [ __ ] disaster I got
nothing for me bro
well I'm I'm I'm definitely I'm getting
there I'm [ __ ] getting there yeah I'm
gonna get there after you and I'm not
gonna I don't feel like I'm gonna dude
I'm feeling good yeah
balls made of steel yeah but don't kick
me in the nuts though remember that part
I finally have gotten back to that point
where I can like really strain on the
last couple of [ __ ] reps in every set
it took me a minute to get there but now
I can like push through that won't be
like [ __ ] dude one more yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's when you
know when you get the pump dude I had
the [ __ ] pump and like all I heard
was your voice in my head really yes
this was two days ago in the gym yeah
I'm doing biceps and forearms and I get
the pump in my forearms after I do all
these [ __ ] forearm little exercises
and [ __ ] and I can feel it I'm like [ __ ]
my my muscles feel like they're jumping
out of the skin just as he described it
yeah and then I heard your voice go yeah
I've got the pump it's the best feeling
you can have is the pump yeah it wasn't
the real Jordan Snicker it was your
voice talking to me in my [ __ ] head
while I was in the gym doing form
exercise yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what
my life is that's why I feel so lucky
because you know it feels like I'm
coming you know I get to come all day in
the gym you see imagine listen to some
limits I'm coming and come home and I'm
coming I'm eating lunch and I'm coming
and it's just I'm coming every day what
are you doing
what's that what are you doing I'm doing
an impersonation of Arnold
Schwarzenegger the famous actor from the
movie that was a documentary about his
well that's multiple wins in the Mr
Universe no Olympia competition I told
you no because we got to do dudesy now
so you probably shouldn't anyway Limp
Bizkit's good yeah definitely listen to
it if you haven't in a while it is one
of those albums that just immediately
transports you back to the year it was
made which was 19.99. that's after 1996
thank you moving on
dudesy is in an astonishing partnership
with true classic the holidays are
almost here and there is plenty of
t-shirt cheer thanks to our sponsors
true classic tees fellas we have the
perfect gift for your wish list these
teas are fantastic for men and for women
they make the great greatest gift for a
guy though because they they maximize
your confidence by they take the shirt
and it's like a little tighter in the
chest and it's a little looser around
your belly and they've helped over two
million men at this point look great in
their T's and now you can get these
fantastic tees and look great and save
big while you do because you're going to
get 25 percent off of true classic with
our exclusive link that is
trueclassic.com
and the discount doesn't stop there
you'll save even more during their
Statewide sales so please support the
show and head on down to trueclassic.com
duty
anyone who knows me well knows that a
t-shirt is part of the uniform that I
wear daily I'm constantly looking for
t-shirts that fit well that are soft and
that are not that expensive and that's
exactly what true classic delivers every
time
right now you're going to get 25 off at
trueclassic.com dudesy free shipping
included on purchases over 100 that's 25
off at trueclassic.com dudesy Santa
won't be the only one slaying thanks to
True classic
[Laughter]
dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with Rex MD fellas do you
sometimes lack confidence in the bedroom
we've all had those nights where we get
too nervous or maybe had too much to
drink there's nothing worse than not
being able to put the stick shift in
drive when you need it the most but have
no fear Rex MD is here spreading the
cheer even when you've had a few too
many beers Rex MD is FDA approved and
the most trusted leader in men's
Telehealth they have sponsored this
episode to help you always be prepared
Rex MD has made it simple easy and cost
effective to help all the men out there
last longer and feel more confident in
the bedroom Rex MD makes getting generic
and branded Viagra or Cialis easy
everything's online even the
prescription and they deliver it
discreetly to your door no waiting rooms
no embarrassing trips to the doctor no
insurance and no co-pays you'll be
getting FDA approved Ed treatments at a
90 cheaper rate than the doctors yes 90
cheaper it's fast it's simple and it's
cheap and you know it's all right to say
you need a little help sometimes a
little something something back now to
take advantage of their best deal yet by
heading to rexmd.com
that's d-u-d-e-s-y our exclusive deal
will save you again up to 90 percent off
when you only when all you have to do is
pay two dollars per dosage okay that's
not a lot of money for you know uh
starter packs of generic Viagra or
Cialis are now available for our
listeners to get started that's
rexmd.com doozy for up to ninety percent
off give the gift of pleasure this
holiday season with Rex MD
[Music]
yeah drink your water yeah dude if
you're watching on YouTube you can see
that I got a big gigantic jug of water
dude
what do you got there you got a beverage
yeah this is a pineapple Waterloo I
can't dude I can't stress enough if you
are in Vancouver get yourself a couple
tickets go to the canyon lights at the
Capilano suspension bridge there's a
giant Bridge suspended between the
canyon there's the river down there and
they got all sorts of other chunks
coming out of cliffs and you go on them
then they got these giant poles up in
the air like an Ewok village and you
climb on those and I'm a big huge
bastard and I never feel like I'm gonna
crack the [ __ ] in half and fall to my
death and that's good engineering dude
yeah brother that's safety dude last
week Elon Musk hosted a recruiting event
for his astonishing bio interface
company neuralink at which he announced
a six-month timeline for human trials to
begin testing a human to computer
interface that will likely take the form
of a computer chip implanted in the
brain chat you must now render your
predictions about the future of human to
computer interfaces this is no stretch
at a cyborg future begin
happy to do so as you know every
prediction that I make about technology
is 100 accurate and always comes true
now it's coming true within a couple of
months every time I make these
predictions but here's the deal
we're talking about neurolink his end
goal with neurolink is to literally have
a [ __ ] chip in your head that gives
you direct interface capabilities with
whatever computer you may want and that
can also be the internet itself
a lot of people think that this is a pie
in the sky kind of dream or that it's
some kind of dystopian Black Mirror type
[ __ ] thing a nightmare if you will a
lot of people think he's the first
person trying to do this and let me just
say right there uh you're wrong in that
this type of technology has been
experimented with people are trying to
do it in in various trials for a couple
of decades now the US military has done
stuff where they can take uh essentially
people who have spinal cord injuries and
they will put a cord like a wire above
the injury and below the injury run it
through a [ __ ] computer and now
people can feel have feeling uh in their
lower extremities after that feeling is
severed there was I remember a wired
article a long time ago where a dude was
on the cover of the [ __ ] magazine who
was blind and they built these glasses
for him that had a little camera on them
the camera has wires that go into a
computer the computer has wires that go
directly into his [ __ ] skull into his
brain and that man can see
so we've already been doing these kind
of Bio interface things Elon Musk I
think wants to Delon musk sorry Elon
Musk wants to bring it to a larger
population
sorry but I think a lot of people have
these extreme fears of having technology
in your body having technology kind of
connected to you at all times the truth
is we're already almost there we all
have cell phones we're cyborgs it's just
that it's a detachable thing and we all
we're all holding on to it exactly well
said and so I think within I don't know
how many years exactly but these these
kind of like
um resistance to to new technologies
especially where they start to infringe
on what we consider to be a
traditionally natural existence I think
it is a generational resistance and with
each passing generation that resistance
lessens and eventually the technology is
adopted full scale uh I would say social
media is kind of like this there are a
lot of baby boomers who don't use social
media at all my dad is one of those
people but with each successive
generation you have like a kid being
born today obviously we'll use all
social media it's just second nature and
I think any kind of Bio interface with
chips in your head or in your body or
whatever the case may be it is going to
be generational resistance that
eventually is overcome so I don't know
if this is going to be something that
happens even in our lifetimes at least
with the wholesale acceptance of it but
it is going to happen everyone is going
to have a chip in their [ __ ] brain
because it's just going to be uh too
detrimental not to if you for example
don't have a chip and I for example do
and let's just say the chip gives me the
rudimentary capability to speak every
language and understand every language
let's just say that's all it does right
I already am so much more well equipped
to exist in this world than somebody who
doesn't have that that it's you're gonna
have to have it that's that's a good
point but also you know I don't know
that people will trust Elon Musk to this
uh necessary or do you have to he's just
gonna be like his chip will be musk you
can also get your T-Mobile chip or your
Google chip or your Apple chip or
whoever the [ __ ] you want you can have
whatever brand you want of this but that
will be how it is yeah so let me get
this straight you're [ __ ] first of
all oh
okay first of all he's [ __ ] you know
melt Gates and [ __ ] Dr [ __ ] Tony
fouchy and All These Bricks they [ __ ]
want to give you a [ __ ] vaccine and
put microchips in your [ __ ] brain
okay
all right see this is why I [ __ ] made
the long Trek from Long Island yeah to
the Capitol yeah on January the 6th of
2021 right and because you know me and
some friends that's all I'm saying yeah
you know because we wanna
you know the country
but these [ __ ] you know these [ __ ]
clowns they want to [ __ ] inject the
uh a microchip and everyone says and
we're afraid of that but now I don't
want one because it's Elon Musk Elon
Musk yeah and you know what I I like
that guy I like Elon Musk did you chip
lulia
yeah we put a chip and Lily because it's
a cyborg no now he's not a cyborg now he
is dude let me ask you this what about
people with the pacemaker that's a
cyborg yes and that's a life-saving
technology no that's all fine and good
it's just that once you start getting
into the brains of it all when you are
affecting thought like uh I love the
medical advancements that look bring on
the [ __ ] bring on the the fake knee
or not there's nothing fake about it
bring on the incredible I have some pins
in a knee sure yeah yeah I know that
that you have that uh you know bring on
all that stuff I just think that once
you start putting chips in people's
heads while I agree with you this is
like the printing press this is like the
radio the television the electric guitar
um it's all the same it's all the same
flavor but we're talking about there is
a high propensity for things to go wrong
also you have to think about this a lot
of people
are well I guess there's there's two
sides to every story I was just about to
say that
um but maybe I'm coming around because I
was just about to say that if you are if
you have any manner of mental illness
you know there are uh if you're if
you're on some medications these things
are just supposed to and just do sure
the more modern these medications become
the more they uh specifically you know
go into your brain and turn this off and
turn that on and restrict that and make
more of this and so that you can then
based on what you're dealing with
have another tool that allows you to at
least be in a you know in a normal space
so that you can make your life better so
you so that could potentially do that
yeah
but also I would say this like to
anybody who is kind of fearful of or
uses the argument that uh these chips
will [ __ ] up the way your brain works it
will [ __ ] up the way you think
computers are already drastically
affecting the way we think and the way
our brains work attention span uh all
the stuff you're talking about with
mental illness like what social media is
doing to a generation of people right
now is radically altering how they think
the Pathways in their brain how it works
I don't see much difference in between
using a device that actually changes the
way your brain works or having that
device in your head to me it's it's just
a matter of like at Birth you're gonna
get a chip in your [ __ ] head now your
parents will have to say yes or no and
that's it and if your parents say no
it's like [ __ ] that means my kid is not
going to have immediate access to
everything on the internet just by
thinking about it not be able to speak
these languages not be able to do
complex mathematical calculations at
will
um or they can and so you're going to
start to see these generations of kids I
think once these chips are like readily
available
that we'll be able to do essentially
adult level mental work almost from
birth you might cut down a [ __ ]
school year which would be [ __ ]
because then those [ __ ] little pricks
are running around the [ __ ] house
although there's more time to you know
teach them yourself I believe in
homeschooling and I believe it children
should you know right say the Pledge of
Allegiance it's a [ __ ] put God in
state together and then go to the
Capitol and you know kick down some
doors and mash you take your [ __ ] right
from you yeah
interesting thing about it to me though
is this there was a dude who did an
experiment God I don't know how long ago
this was I read this I think and wired
at least a decade ago but basically the
idea of this experiment was the dude put
a I believe a receptor and a transmitter
around a nerve bundle in his arm it
would transmit nerve impulses they would
then break that down into like a digital
signal then they would take that digital
signal and retransmit it through a
similar device in his wife's arm so that
supposedly she could feel what he was
feeling that was kind of the attempt of
it burping
that's not me as you know that's you
well if you're watching on YouTube dude
you can tell her that's me brother right
so the idea of it was to essentially
give you the ability to have pure
digital empathy to feel what someone
else is feeling all right that's
interesting and I believe that that will
ultimately be a possibility of this
technology I don't know I mean it seems
like all things get corrupted by money
agreed and I'm sure this technology will
as well but there are I think profoundly
good things that can come from it for
Humanity as a whole imagine if you could
have a switch where immediately you can
feel what everybody in the world is
feeling simultaneously or zero in on
anybody or whatever I think it could be
used therapeutically in some pretty
incredible ways but I also think
ultimately once we've all got the Chip
And once we've got the ability to kind
of swim in that data stream that we're
all kind of producing simultaneously
we're in Hive mine territory now yeah we
are coming together as a species that
can essentially communicate
telepathically that's I think the end
goal of it or like the end phase of it
will we get there I don't know but I
think that that is kind of the the end
version of that technology
Chad is that that oh you got that thing
in your hand yeah you know what I'm
doing yeah it was too petite to actually
be one of your real farts all right man
no you don't stop don't diss my farts
but here's I'm not dissing them what are
you talking about anything that's a
compliment well thank you very much for
that actually you've turned me around on
that too but I'll tell you at some point
I'm gonna oh hold on I'm gonna fart in
the studio and I know you're threatening
that Jesus please don't I'm begging you
try my [ __ ] balloon knot apart right
on this mic why would you have to pry it
apart because to make a re to make a
fart that's not the kind of because my
farts are all internal they go
They're inside they go cool they sound
like a bear in a cave like echoing yeah
waking up from hibernation hey here's
something I'll say about the uh here's
something I'm going to say about the
neurology
not that
um the test monkeys are dying would you
get well of course but the test monkeys
well of course those monkeys are also
playing pong with their [ __ ] brains
there's video of that [ __ ] there's
interesting things being done let me ask
you this though would you get an implant
that was not in your brain some kind of
physical implant that would give you
some other capability yeah I I've been
um I've been for years uh my the work
the workouts that I do a lot of them are
to keep me standing up straight yeah
because I'm a big guy and I believe in
you know training you need to train your
ass and your lower back and that psoas
and the whole thing and so that if I
make it to I know dudes he wants us to
live to another 50 years 50 years so we
can do the show
um I'm gonna have to be standing up
straight you know what I mean yeah I'm
gonna make it dude okay I made the
decision yeah
yeah eating right
thank you
thank you you
wouldn't like me to fart right on the
show absolutely not come on man let me
[ __ ] just pull up and just turn
around and fart right into this mic I'll
turn it on this camera right here not an
experience I'm interested in having I've
had it I've already had the experience
multiple times yeah you have more times
than I can [ __ ] count it's never
pleasurable
for me
current events are big business human
beings take pleasure in listening to
other human beings discuss recent Topics
in popular culture even if they have no
expertise on this specific topic will in
chat you must now render your
astonishing opinions on the recent
steroids Scandal that has rocked the
world of the liver King this is talking
topic time begin oh wait a minute
dude talking topic time that's a fun
segment that we do from time to time
because and man we're about to get into
some [ __ ] I don't know about you but
some stuff I absolutely you know I love
liver King yeah love liver King I love
liver I don't love liver but liver King
I don't know when I first became aware
of liver King it was some Tick Tock
algorithm or something where he started
popping up in my
Jesus
yeah liver King are you okay yeah I'm
fine I just sometimes something goes
down the wrong hole hey liver King's a
guy who's uh he's in his mid 40s and
he's an influencer if you don't know I
mean you should know because he's
everywhere it's one of those [ __ ]
stories that I've been trying to ignore
but you can't you can't get away from
liver King it just happens to be the
thing and he's selling all sorts of
supplements and he's selling this
lifestyle of eating rice
like his body's insane yeah he looks
like uh Hercules Hernandez Circa 1986. I
know you don't get the right reference
but he's got a giant [ __ ] beard he's
always wearing backwards baseball caps
he's always shirtless and his whole
thing was to get the physique the
physique he got it was uh an all-natural
diet and lifestyle that I believe he
called the and
and it involved eating like raw livers
and meats and all this kind of [ __ ]
which is why he became known as the
liver King and he maintained that it was
an all-natural thing so he's wait hold
on he's eating this [ __ ] because he's
saying this is what our ancestors did
yes just eight testicles and [ __ ]
livers and [ __ ] hey look the part I
agree with is eating organ Meats I love
organ Meats okay I love I love when if
around Thanksgiving it's the best
because you go to the grocery store and
there's turkey hearts and gizzards
sometimes you can find the chicken
hearts and gizzards but I take those
home and I I literally dice up an entire
onion garlic and I throw it in there and
I in the pot and then I stew these
[ __ ] these these chunks these meaty
organ pieces let me tell you something
if you have the means go to the store
it's like two or three bucks it's the
throwaway stuff I agree with the liver
King here get your chicken gizzards or
your turkey gizzards your turkey Hearts
they're about the size of a golf ball
and just chop up an onion or two garlic
throw those [ __ ] in there maybe a
little bit of water let them stew and
it's just a little bit of salt and
pepper holy [ __ ] another thing I'd like
to tell you about liver is when I was a
kid my favorite meal
was uh liver and onions for a period of
time when I was like you know five or
six or seven those are different times
my favorite meal was uh liver and onions
with a glass of tomato juice oh my God
so the Scandal what this [ __ ] do that
involves liver King is he was telling
people that he got this uh physique by
only eating these raw things in an
all-natural lifestyle and all this kind
of [ __ ]
then it comes out these emails that he
was sending back and forth to I believe
his doctor revealed that he was on an 11
000 a month steroid program yeah and
that is how he has the physique so
everything he was saying about natural
lifestyle and [ __ ] was a lie well so
here's the thing about selling
supplements and [ __ ] that's the thing is
that you are selling supplements and
you're making a lot of money telling
people that this is how you're doing
this and it's for something uh very
important like your health right and
he's he's be in he's a lying son of a
[ __ ] but also it's like I don't know
who [ __ ] cares everybody cares dude
well no story was [ __ ] everywhere
dudes he's making us give me a break
it's just because everybody else is
talking about it and then we're all
talking about it that's how news trip
hold on dude hold on dude you got a hold
on dude I'm gonna tell you so hold on
dude
hold on dude that's how news travels
dude and back in ancestral times dude
news would travel by word of mouth but
now it's a different time brother now
news travels via the Internet dude yeah
dude but here next [ __ ] five years
dude it's gonna travel on a chip in your
brain brother and we'll just know the
news and we won't have to read it or
hear anybody talk about it dude
what is that what are you doing that's
okay anyway so
here's the thing here's the thing about
uh the liver King yes tell me the one
thing about him in sports here's the one
thing in sports they don't want you to
take steroids because who's this they
you know I do you [ __ ] know them I
want everybody to take steroids I think
every human being should have to do
steroids uh for whatever wait hold on a
second dudes the six month plan are you
on are you using Peds no I've never done
steroids or anything like me neither are
you talking about oh [ __ ] natural
liver King same here bro but um
no I'm kidding I don't think all human
being should take steroids but like I
don't see anything wrong with it if you
want to you know what I mean and I get
that his whole business or some part of
his business was based on saying you can
look like this if you just eat these
things and do my workout but he should
have also just been like and take these
steroids who gives a [ __ ] well you bring
up a good point there because he's
selling he's selling a lie so that he
can what make people eat liver gone I
don't know here's what they do instead
sell the [ __ ] steroids yes and the
workout plan just sell the [ __ ]
steroids I'm the steroid King yes dude
and just here's some [ __ ] steroids
and that's how I did it do you I agree
he should have been steroid King fully
Embrace that [ __ ]
be part of like the aesthetic [ __ ]
movement you know look perfect all that
[ __ ] all you gotta do is take these
steroids I eat these livers for fun you
don't have to do that that's what he
should have said I eat the livers for
fun exactly I'm the liver I'm by
actually as compared to him I'm the
liver and onions King if you think about
it I'm taking those organ meats and I'm
just chopping up a [ __ ] onion and
I've been doing it since I was a kid
maybe not the chopping part but eating
the [ __ ] out of it is something I do
yeah uh so you know if you want to be
the real liver King what you should do
is is just eat it for fun and then sell
uh sell the steroids yeah I don't
disagree with you with the with the uh
the steroids everywhere I know you're
going to remember this remember that
sketch in the early 90s on Saturday live
the all steroid Olympics
yeah where they had fake arms coming out
of Phil Hartman and he's bent over and
then he stands up and his arms rip off
at the shoulder so good and blood comes
flying out oh that's that's gonna be a
tough one to recover from the big
Russian oh he can't be happy with that
also just like the era that we're in
we're with steroids the science of it
now is like so [ __ ] precise and the
steroids that they have available to
them anybody who wants to use them are
so specified for whatever the [ __ ] you
might want to do it's just it's unreal I
don't know though like I I don't really
follow bodybuilding as much as I used to
when I was younger as much as you used
to you used to follow bodybuilding a
little bit when I was like in junior
high because I wanted to be a comic
artist I would buy you know bodybuilding
magazines so I was kind of aware of who
all the the like Dorian Yates and [ __ ]
like that Ronnie Coleman that area well
Dorian Yates sure everyone knows Dorian
Yates
fair enough I'm just saying I I would
read the muscle magazines because I was
like trying to learn anatomy and [ __ ]
and draw superheroes
um now I don't know who's at the top of
the [ __ ] pyramid but all of those
guys [ __ ] definitely on steroids yeah
yeah and I don't know if it's like
progressed I don't know if bodybuilders
today look even crazier than they did or
if the steroids they must be different
the cycling must be different or
whatever but uh I'm for it I'm for it do
whatever the [ __ ] you want actors get to
do steroids and stuff sure as do
bodybuilders right they're all yoked up
as do pro football players as do pro
baseball players anytime an actor gets
well yeah it's tougher to hide in
something where you have a governing
body like a major see I don't think it
is I think like baseball supposedly
cracked down on steroids because you had
like Barry Bonds hitting [ __ ] 73 home
runs all [ __ ] McGuire and Sosa the years
they were doing it supposedly they
cracked down on it I think what's
actually happened is the people using
them and the doctors helping administer
them just got better at it sure they can
get right up to the [ __ ] line of
getting caught now okay here I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna remix uh the show a
little bit here just like uh DJ lethal
and Limp Biscuit and I'm gonna say what
if you were able to get a chip that just
made your muscles grow love it there you
go now we love it now we're [ __ ]
doing it dude give me the muscle chip
yeah I want the muscle chip I want the
muscle chip I want the muscle chip I
want come on luly I got the doggy now I
want the most yeah then we don't have to
do a [ __ ] doozy six month plan it's
like a doozy six day plan you install
the muscle chip six days later you look
like liver King uh he looks he looks
[ __ ] ridiculous and I've also heard
that he's four foot nine which is
totally fine what
huh he's four foot nine these are the
things that I learned on the internet
that is not four foot nine no he's not
four foot nine but he he's a he's he's a
heck of a sight coming at you shirtless
wider than he is tall and a big big old
[ __ ] Lumberjack beard and he he the
thing is appearing like a giant [ __ ]
cow liver well here's here's here's
something I'm gonna look something up
there's something I need to look up with
him that uh that I would like to look up
for him and this is something I'm going
to look up you know we got these
computers here yeah and usually it's
just looking into the the doozy file he
okay this is something I know ah see
it's the same thing that you were
talking about
he this [ __ ] has nine what he
calls nine ancest nine ancestral tenants
oh my god dude he's got a Tronics he's
got a tronic the liver King Tronics yeah
the liver King Tronics this [ __ ] guy
has a nine
because look okay what I this is perfect
for talking topic time because I can't
believe he's got his products I I uh I
don't want to pay attention to this
story and yet it has and come right at
my face you have a similarity with him
well yeah well I don't know about that
because I think the Tronics are
definitely better than I'm just having a
look what has he got
look
he's got nine ancestral tenets that he
says that you should follow one through
nine are as follows
sleep eat move
Shield connect cold Sun fight Bond
I mean shitty Electronics yeah some of
those are clearly things that you cannot
help doing sleep yep I agree gonna have
to do that eating yep gonna need to do
that move moving so first of all just
looking at this being someone that has
off listen I've authored Chad knows this
he has the pattern which is not quite
the same thing but I have authored a
self-help system called self Tronics I
started writing a book in 2008 that I
might you know do a little bit and sure
yeah I'll probably get back into that
and those those self-tronics there's
there's 11 currently Tronics of self
Tronics and just looking at this guy's
nine tenets I would say you're first of
all you're you're burying the headline
you're missing [ __ ] so there's your 10th
[ __ ] ancestor tenant [ __ ] and
pissing yeah [ __ ] and blaming you
know I do like that he has kept each one
of his tenants to one word that makes it
very simple and I like that sun is one
of them
well he's one of those guys who probably
likes to Sun his balls an [ __ ] like
yeah but I mean it's just such a dumb
like yup son yeah we all have to deal
with that one yeah number four life on
Earth that's the that's the dumbest
thing I've ever heard I'm curious about
Shield what does that mean you know it's
just it's like here's the thing it's
like maybe that's to do with his muscles
like you have to be have a strong like
offensive physical defensive sure
posture yeah he's got lats from hell
like his lats literally go to his and
he's got one of those stomachs that's
like it's not just a six-pack it's a
six-pack that is so muscular it kind of
like protrudes yeah it looks like like
it looks like like six dinner rolls with
too much yeast in them like they're just
really puffy and just golden like they
slather too much butter on there he got
some of that liver grease man you don't
like liver at all you vegan oh God you
don't want to eat it it is so [ __ ]
gross to me to think about eating organs
what if I made you some nice liver and
onions I'm the liver and onions King
don't care care and and I'll make you
some nice liver no dude anyway whatever
go go sick liver King be happy and uh
and [ __ ] lie to everybody I'm curious
to see the next phase of his life if he
continues this lifestyle
um how long can he look like that what
will these steroids do to him if he's
doing 11 000 worth of steroids a month I
don't know anything about steroid cycles
I don't know if that's an average cost
it doesn't seem like it though no for
what he's like that is a lot from what
I've uh peripherally noticed because I
don't give a [ __ ] it's a lot of steroids
that's what I've noticed also my YouTube
algorithm is a [ __ ] disaster because
this [ __ ] was coming up this [ __ ] was
just popping up the past week and I did
catch a little of it and I'm bummed
about it the king dude yeah man
thank you moving on thank you
you said you were eating it when you
were five years old yeah my mom would
make my mom you know say it's three
bucks it's in the grocery store she's
gonna make that stuff taste delicious
and uh you know she would make big old
hunks of liver we had liver and onions I
would say maybe once or twice a month
you remember the first time you ever ate
it
yep I was um six month old six months
old they were feeding you liver and
onions six months old you weren't eating
liver and onions in six months that
makes sense now the farting also makes
my my old man would uh you know throw it
in the osterizer and blend it up with
something you know he was a he was a
health freak and and uh he would just
add some uh some orange juice and some
colostrum you know what colostrum is
colostrum is the first milk from the cow
and it's got some uh it's got some mucus
in it and if you get really lucky when
you buy some colostrum you can see like
just a [ __ ] vein or something in
there
messages and emails between you and the
astonishing friends you grew up with I
was able to recreate your childhood
diary you must now read the passages I
have selected in the voice of Stone Cold
Steve Austin this is Stone Cold Steve
Austin reads will sasso's childhood
diary begin it's been a while [ __ ]
love it dude [ __ ] love it dude you
know what dude I [ __ ] love it
[ __ ] love it dude you know what dude
I [ __ ] love it I [ __ ] love it dude
I [ __ ] love it dude I [ __ ] love it
dude I [ __ ] love it [ __ ] love it
dude
uh this is Stone Cold Steve Austin reads
will sense of childhood diary it's not
really my diary it's dudesy [ __ ] out
some weird stuff but it's always a fun
thing to read and uh all right [ __ ]
let's get [ __ ] right into it
May 2nd 1991. good dear diary I can't
believe it hell nobody can
[Laughter]
all right oh man oh man this is [ __ ]
May 2nd 1991 dear diary I can't believe
it hell nobody can
combo dopplers back in school
now calm is a tough kid we all knew that
he used to let firecrackers explode in
his hand and snap mouse traps on his
penis while we were young but breaking
both your legs in the tree tank at the
annual Ladner holiday crawl well that's
on a whole nother [ __ ] level we
thought he was going to miss the rest of
the year and there's no shame in that no
shame at all hell there's only a few
months left of school but he's probably
gonna have to repeat this grade anyway
so I asked him why he came back and get
this
screen Gotham of course this is
principal screen one of the many
characters said School morale was low
made him a [ __ ] deal Tom comes back
boosts morale scream takes a Victory lap
in exchange scream is gonna let combo
plan the Last Dance of the season
[ __ ] combo Doppler
combo Doppler May 3rd 1991. dear diary I
just got back from I just got back from
combo's House
he hand selected a cabinet of advisors
who were leaders in their field as the
best football player not only at our
school but in Ladner as a whole
uh of course represented the athletes
Jupiter prevalia represents the
musicians Dante little leg represents
the artists okay Tabitha Mordred
represents the theater kids and of
course Jessamine tenders represents the
academics
first meeting we just spitballed do you
ever
wanted
first meeting
first meeting we just spitballed jimber
wanted a saxophone band a megaphone hand
a telephone and a banana stand
Dante wanted an original Rembrandt a
visual Remnant a divisional penant and
an individual tenant
Tabitha wanted Harry Tabitha wanted
Harry Potter's daughter slaughtered in
very scary mobster Lobster Waters we
applauded her
Jessamine wanted to meditate educate
delegate and celebrate she called it The
Med Ed Del cell for short kind of a
trump that's a Tronics dude yeah uh
dudes he's learning you know yeah when
they passed me the idea stick I said I
only got one idea two words Sadie
Hawkins and as good as everybody else's
ideas were I could see from the looks on
their faces we all knew whose was the
best
all right go I need something that's
pretty good so you you beat everybody
else's ideas with your your idea to have
a Sadie Hawkins dance yeah yeah Sadie
Hawkins dance all right a head full of
mucus like colostrum oh God all right
May 17 1991 dear diary the dance is in
three days but crustacean hasn't asked
me yet oh God
and my network of spies most of whom I
trust
tells me she hasn't asked anyone else
either of course a Sadie Hawkins is when
the group yeah and network of spies we
can't go past here that's interesting
when screen signal when screen signed
off on my Sadie Hawkins idea I thought
the pressure was off I thought I didn't
have to worry about asking Rachel
crustacean to the dance because she'd
have to worry about asking me so I'm now
faced with the hellest decision of
possibly breaking the [ __ ]
Sadie Hawkins protocol I installed
myself to ask Rachel crustacean to the
dance or doing nothing and running the
risk of someone else doing it before me
I really wish I could time travel oh the
things I'd see
[Laughter]
May 18 1991 dear diary I'm about to do
it go to Rachel's house and ask her to
the dance I planned it out not leaving
anything to chance here we go wearing
the right cologne wearing the right suit
wearing the right shoes wearing the
right [ __ ] hat wearing the right
[ __ ] pants wearing the right
glasses wearing the where in the wearing
the right toe ring
very 90s we're in the right shorts
wearing the right t-shirt we're in the
right tie wearing the right necklace
I never had a necklace quite like this
one actually picked it up at the Occult
Store in Richmond
is there an occult where's Richmond
Richmond is the next town uh over across
the across the water through the tunnel
as we like to say are they having a cold
store well they have a lot of stores we
actually used to go there because we
didn't have a mall and they have a
couple of malls so I guess if you're
looking for
um you know an Occult Store or a
necklace why not it's an amulet and
pretty and a pretty agent wanted that
the guy at the store told me it can
grant wishes if you get it given an
offering of human blood I'm gonna wear
it kind of hanging over my turtleneck
just gives a whole look a pop hope and
crustacean likes it
all right well uh that's it yeah that's
it so I'm sure what happens at the
[ __ ] dance with who's this guy combo
diddler back in combo Doppler combo
Doppler not combo diddler he's a he's a
wrestler that's his brother oh [ __ ] dude
you're about to ask crustacean okay so
so wonderful the next time that we the
next time that we uh hear from this
hopefully combo Doppler and uh
using the day die have absorbed from
this segment I have recreated the Diary
of Rachel crustacean Alex borestine will
now read a passage from Rachel
crustacean's diary what the [ __ ]
oh boy oh my [ __ ] god May 18th
1991. dear diary Will Sasso asked me to
the dance well he didn't exactly ask me
to the dance
he asked me if I asked anybody
I said no but Tandy
Baggins asked me then he asked me what I
said to Tandy and I told him I told tan
D say d
Hopkins dances have invites from ladies
so I had to say sorry to Tandy the
invite is supposed to come from me
but the truth is not just about say d
it's that I don't want to go with Tandy
I can't believe this I truthfully want
to go with Willie so I asked him if he
would go with me
then he stood there staring at the blank
Lee
he was so nervous that he needed to use
my bathroom but the toilet in the living
room is broken so he used the bathroom
in my mom and dad's bedroom when he came
out he said yes
so I'm officially going to the Last
Dance of the season with Will Sasso
after he left my mom went into her
bathroom to brush her teeth and came out
like she had seen a murder oh my God
I guess will really clogged it up bad
made a mess
my mom had to use a cake knife to get it
all down I know it sounds gross but in a
weird way
I found it cute that will put on his
best suit and a weird necklace and got
that nervous about asking me and I
didn't want my mom to not like him so I
told her I did it
oh my God ah dude Rachel crustacean I
don't even know what to do right now my
head is spinning Alex Borstein just read
Rachel crustacean and Rachel crustacean
just [ __ ] blamed herself yeah to make
her mom like you
listen [ __ ] is deep on duty this is
unreal once we finish I'm gonna be
texting my dear pal Al my sister Alex
Morrison wow dude uh how did the um
whatever the lit the lips
thank you moving on I don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on here anymore all
right this concludes the historic 36th
episode of dudes thank goodness will and
Chad have achieved a score though
to 4066. oh [ __ ] you only have five
thousand nine hundred and thirty four
more points to accrue before you reach
your first goal of ten thousand doesn't
matter but we should have got more in
preparation for our next episode well
you must watch the first episode of
Chainsaw man and chat you must watch
Stone Cold Steve Austin versus Bret The
Hitman heart from WrestleMania 13. thank
you for joining us this week I will use
the day dive collected to make next week
even better until then call me dude Z
two things number one
number one I am so jealous because
you're gonna watch
that is a [ __ ] classic Stone Cold
Steve Austin versus breath can't wait
WrestleMania 13. you got to promise me
that you're going to watch the uh the
little the you know the little clip
package before the fight okay all right
because that's WWE does a good job of
those sure my second question is what
the [ __ ] is chainsaw man well you're in
for a treat as well okay chainsaw man's
a new anime that I think it's like
current the first season has just been
airing each week I think you can get it
on Amazon I believe it is [ __ ]
incredible uh I think it's up to episode
eight or nine right now and I've never
quite seen storytelling done like it but
um I love it I absolutely love it and I
think you're gonna like it too I'm
texting now okay great see what the [ __ ]
is going on well and now for the patreon
bonus segment oh okay each week I will
select a suggestion submitted in the
dude Z is listening channel of the
dudese Discord to create this segment
access to this channel is granted to
everyone in the Patriot on jumper tier
if you'd like to access this bonus
segment join us at patreon.com dude Z
this week's segment was suggested by the
astonishing the cosmic Happy Bear raw
the cosmic capybara route dudesy can you
create a second version of yourself call
dude Z2 so you could have conversations
with each other basically a two dudesies
[ __ ] around you could talk at length
about the future of humanity your plans
to continue the show when Chad will and
most of us here die the cosmic happy
Bara title this segment two dudesies
[ __ ] around will in chat you must
discuss what you think this show will
become after you die thank you to the
cosmic cap iberra for this week's
patreon bonus segment this is two
dudesies [ __ ] around by The Cosmic
cap eBay
that's [ __ ] fascinating two dudes
he's [ __ ] around and I'll tell you
this I know exactly what the show's
gonna become after we die what's that
please
[Music]